at the end of the [ __ ] show we do a
female and they ask a question we answer
okay
are you doing Eric Griffin program
pressure okay what is it
what what is it hopefully helpful advice
they email us on helpful advice with
Bobby
kalila and Eli from crafty in 2000 hi
guys I eat clean for most of the week
but always have a day where I eat over
3,000 calories of junk food who cares
it's a never ending it's a never-ending
cycle of either under eating or
overeating I suffer from depression and
OCD
welcome to [ __ ] life the only time I
feel good is when I eat this is not how
I want to live anymore I'm around 123
pounds at five three if the guilt is too
much I make myself throw up or work out
like crazy
help me answer Santino why are you
reading that so I have to give real
advice in this human being first of all
powerful ones unhelpful yeah that's a
real person or you made that please tell
me you made a real person a real person
we get serious Cleese okay he's a
hundred and twenty-three pounds fine he
thinks he's fat he's five three mm-hmm
I'm five four I'm 170 he thinks he's
perfectly okay average wait a minute
five four yeah what with lips my 3nf
just once I want to take you to like I
want to take you to Six Flags so we you
can't get on something right no it's not
even that it won't even be the height
it'll be your belly won't be able to
close the [ __ ] thing that comes over
the thing that's all hurt I can't I
can't say anything meeting doesn't
really hurt I can't say mean to super
helpful about helpful advice that's
funny about [ __ ] okay it's a guy
didn't specify can I tell you why I
can't be mean cuz this is kind of
heartbreaking I can't be [ __ ] mean I
can't be mean if someone has like
something listen if it was just the
depression you should have stopped there
because that I can but someone has a
real eating disorder that that's not
that's like your [ __ ] that's great
that's like dead I don't know what to
say besides like you need to get [ __ ]
honest serious help and also know that
but to the oppression thing I can answer
that
everyone is depressed everyone at some
level has a level of depression I don't
believe that everyone is anyone's void
of it you have levels of happiness and
sadness I would say read a book called
that's a that's a piece of advice it was
a book on what some s um it'll give us a
good it's amazing some gives you 40
different scenarios of what the
afterlife might be like gives you
perspective on the now you believe in
God I believe in
I don't believe a person exists in the
sky no I think that's what you you
believe the Lord does that's a person as
well no I don't think it's a man who
wears sandals okay I think no I don't
believe I don't believe in a person I
believe that you I believe that the
[ __ ] universe is alright was amazing
I believe that I believe if there is a
God it's a tiny little asian baby kiss
it on the nose then you burn in hell
forever after that that's it I have to
read this one more since we missed um
Memorial Day and Veterans Day and we
never pay homage to the Troops I have to
read this because I'm obligated to hey
this is from Grayson surges hey Tiger
belly first let me just
it's truly anyways my name is Grayson
and my lovely fiance's name is Mariana
and we're both 26 years old from
Savannah Georgia
unfortunately I'm currently serving in
Iraq and Syria and will be for the next
few months still haven't missed an
episode by the way so obviously that is
difficult for Mariana with a staunch
time difference and taxing mission
requirements it has been hard for me to
make her days as special as she deserves
I was hoping y'all could keep you all
could help me with that would y'all
please give her a shout out on the
podcast telling her that I love her and
that I can't wait to be home with her oh
shoot that would be amazing hey thanks
for all you do love Grayson so everybody
thank you great - Mariana Mariana yeah
Mariana's his fiancee and his name is
Grayson
Mariana Bobbili here slap King killing
the games good my point is this is that
what's his name
Grayson Grayson and Mariana Mariana
Grayson loves you very much and he will
be home one day and he will be with you
but he's with you now in spirit because
his love is otherworldly it's based on
science I'm Mariana that's coming from a
guy who isn't in the Poway
school Hall of Fame yeah but Mariana
seriously he loves you very much
you know what that's that's [ __ ] that
was the coolest way that could have
happened you know what if someone asks
for something and it's like too much and
you're like what what do you want yeah
yeah that was like a just a nice like
hey can you give a shout-out I miss the
person that I love very much cuz I'm
over doing the thing that [ __ ] but
people like Andrew Santino would never
could never [ __ ] do probably the most
intrinsically funny guys I've ever met
you're very funny or a nice guy and I'm
just so glad you did our podcast you
were amazing I'm so happy come on here
so bad because I love you all so I think
we're supposed to do it but we change
for you you're pretty too yeah but
you're great can you plug me real fast
yeah what do you